- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe in,
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope that
if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is show up.
Over to you Brene Brown.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me a going
- My story is that I am a researcher
and I never thought I would
have a big public career.
And so I did a Ted talk
that went very viral
and in the wake of that,
I was kind of everywhere
for a couple of months
on every CNN.com, in
PR, it was everywhere,
and something that I wasn't used to.
And the marching orders from my therapist
and my husband were do not
read the comments online.
(audience laughs)
So I read all the comments online.
And so one morning I woke up
and there were two or three
new articles out and I
started reading the comments.
And they were devastating.
They weren't about my
work, they were about me,
they were super personal.
And they were the things that
creative people play in their mind
and then give up doing what
they really want to do.
Like if I asked every single one of you,
what would you try if you knew
people would never say this about you?
What would this be?
Those were the comments that morning.
Of course, she embraces imperfection,
what choice does she have?
Look at how she looks.
I feel sorry for her kids.
Less research more Botox.
Just mean personal attacks,
the things that really
up until that moment had
inspired me to stay very small
in my life and in my career.
Just so I could avoid those things.
So that morning, Steve and
the kids leave, I stay home.
I get on the couch
and I watch eight hours of Downtown Abbey.
(audience laughs)
And when it's over, I don't
want to turn off Downtown Abbey,
'cause the minute you
turn off Downtown Abbey,
then it's like soccer practice and dinner
and back to the mean people,
and maybe should I get Botox?
Maybe, you know, maybe if
I stand still when I talk.
So I get out my laptop and I do a search
for who was president in the United States
during the Downtown Abbey era.
Have you ever done that,
like you're numbing with TV
or a movie and so when
it's over, you just like,
you stay in that space by learning more
about the actors and what's going on?
I've been doing this long enough to know
that this is like you're
laughing with me not at me.
(audience laughs)
And so I put it in and
Theodore Roosevelt comes up
and a quote comes up, and I read it.
And this is what it says.
It's a quote from a speech that he gave
in the early 1900s at the Sorbonne,
and a lot of people call it
The Man in the Arena Speech.
And this is the passage
that changes my life.
"It's not the critic who counts,
"it's not the man who points
out how the strong man stumbles
"or where the doer of deeds
could've done it better,
"the credit belongs to the person
"who's actually in the arena
"whose face is marred with
blood and sweat and dust,
"who at the best, in the
end, knows the triumph
"of high achievement and who at worst,
"if he fails, he fails daring greatly."
So the moment that I read
that, I close my laptop
and this is what shifted
in me, three huge things.
First, I spent the last 12
years studying vulnerability,
and that quote was everything
I know about vulnerability.
It is not about winning,
it's not about losing,
it's about showing up and being seen.
The second thing, this
is who I want to be.
I want to create, I want to make things
that didn't exist before I touched them.
I want to show up and be seen
in my work and in my life.
And if you're going to
show up and be seen,
there's only one guarantee and that is
you will get your ass kicked.
That is the guarantee, that is
the only certainty you have.
If you're going to go in the
arena and spend any time in there
whatsoever, especially if
you've committed to creating
in your life, you will
get your ass kicked.
So you have to decide at that moment,
I think for all of us, if
courage is a value that we hold,
this is a consequence, you can't avoid it.
The third thing, which really set me free
and I think Steve my husband would argue
has made me somewhat dangerous
is kind of the new philosophy
about criticism which is this:
if you're not in the arena
also getting your ass kicked,
I'm not interested in
your feedback, period.
(audience applauds)
- What are the hardest parts
about being an entrepreneur
is you put your idea out
there and it gets rejected.
It doesn't work.
Much more worrisome
than failing for people
is failing in front of other people,
to have this new product you create,
or new service you create,
and you put it out there,
and you don't get customers or even worse,
your friends and your
family or people around you
tell you it's never going to work out,
and then it doesn't and then
you failed in front of them.
And most people are so
afraid of that failure,
of failing in front of
people that they care about,
that they don't do anything.
Because you have this plan,
this thing that you want to do,
this great idea that you think
is going to change your life
and help the people around you,
but because it may not work out,
because you don't have the
certainty that it's going to work,
you play small and you
don't do anything about it.
And there has to be a
point that you decide
whether you are going to live
according to your own
expectations or somebody else's.
Like how long are you willing to let
other people's opinions
and perspectives of you
hold you back from doing the
thing that you want to do?
A lot of times those perspectives
and opinions will be wrong,
a lot of times your friends
and family are actually cheering you on,
you still just don't want to
fail in front of other people,
but sometimes is may be true.
Sometimes your Uncle Joe will say,
"You're never going to
make it, look at you,
"look at your education
and your background,
"and your family or how
much money you have.
"You don't have the skills to do that."
And he may be right.
But you won't know until you
actually go out and test it.
And I relate and I resonate.
In my first business when
I was making $300 a month,
I turned down the high-paying
jobs that I thought I wanted,
that my friends all wanted, and
I was too embarrassed and
ashamed to tell my friends
that I had no money, that
I couldn't go out to beer
and grab, you know, beer
and pizza with them.
And I had to pick one thing
month that I could go to,
'cause that's all I could afford.
But I was too embarrassed
and ashamed to tell them.
When they asked how I
was doing, I would say,
you know, I'm living the
entrepreneur lifestyle,
everything's great,
I'm just hustling hard,
I'm working, I'm working.
But really I was just, I
couldn't afford to go out.
And I'm sure if I actually told them that,
they would understand, and
they would have my back,
and they would've been
supportive and encouraging.
Maybe some of them would've razzed me,
but I think that they
would've supported me.
And that would've actually
been very helpful to me,
'cause at the time I was dealing
with everything by myself.
I was trying to internalize everything,
and to the outside world,
be seen as a success.
I think about my friend
who really wanted to get
in front of the camera.
He was a guy who was behind
the camera all the time,
and he wanted to be in
front of the camera.
And one day I forced him,
I pushed him to be in front of the camera.
And I asked him, why are you so afraid
to be in front of the camera?
You want to do this, like
you want to spread a message.
Why are you so afraid to
get in front of the camera?
He was worried about what
his friends would say
on Facebook if they saw a video of him,
he's worried there'd be a negative vibe,
he's worried they wouldn't support him,
and so I did something dramatic.
You know, I filmed him,
I said, enough of this,
we're going to film you,
we're going to put you
in front of the camera.
I put him in front of the
camera and he shared his message
and then I posted the video
and I posted it to Facebook
and I tagged him and I
contacted his wife, and
I had her contact all of his friends
who I didn't have as mutual friends,
and say, hey, watch this video.
And something amazing happened.
All of his friends were super supportive,
were encouraging him,
were cheering him on,
where he thought there'd
be this negative buzz,
negative vibe, judgment,
a lot of negativity, and
it was the exact opposite.
They supported him and wanted
him to go and have success.
And when he saw that difference,
that sparked a shift for him.
And then he started getting
in front of the camera.
And he's been unafraid to get
in front of the camera ever since.
He's created a lot of
interviews, a lot of videos,
a lot of moving videos, some
with me, some with others,
where now he enjoys being
in front of the camera.
Just because he was living
according to what he thought
his friends would think, and
experiencing their support
and kind of being pushed
into the limelight
made that shift for him.
But I said it was going
to work out like that.
Sometimes you will fall flat on your face.
Sometimes people may laugh at you,
sometimes the people in
your network will tell you
that you suck and that you're
never going to be a success.
You just have to decide
at what point in your life
are you going to show up and do the thing
that you want to do and get a result
and just see if it works,
versus just sitting in your head
all day wishing you could do something,
but being afraid because of other people's
expectations and perceptions.
At some point you have to say,
I've had enough.
I don't care what you guys think.
I'm going to go out and do it,
because I need to prove
to myself that I can,
or at least I need certainty that I can't.
So the question today is I'm curious
what has prevented you
from truly showing up?
From really releasing the
message or the product
or service, or the business
that you have inside you,
what has prevented you from
really going all at it?
What are you so afraid of?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
And if you leave a comment
within the first couple of hours
of the video going live,
you have a good chance
of winning one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Mary.
Mary, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word and taking that picture,
it looks great leaning
up against your laptop.
I hope you enjoyed the book,
and I really appreciate your support.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I had a path.
I knew where my path was.
My path was to become what I am right now.
Now, I lost sight of it in
an interesting sort of way
or I went about it
in a wayward path.
But fortunately for me,
all the getting high,
the drinking, the drugs,
everything else I did,
I showed up at the theater every day.
I did plays, ripped out of my mind,
I rehearsed, ripped out of my mind,
but every lesson that I learned,
I held on to for some reason.
God, whatever, somebody let me hold on
to everything that I was learning.
My stage lefts, my stage rights,
my upstage foot always
out, turn down this way,
learning how to develop a character,
doing all those things,
because those are the things that I love.
And I did them in the
midst of everything else
that I was doing to,
you know, when my friends
were getting ready
to go get some more drugs, I go,
and I got to be at the theater.
And I'll catch you all when
the theater's over, you know,
when I'm done, and I'd shew, I'd jet.
Or I got to go build a
set, I got to do this.
So I did everything that I had to do.
So I was focused on this
by any means necessary.
Plus I had a professor
who was like, you know,
well, you know, all the
great ones do their jobs
and they ripped out of the their minds.
You know, you look at the Peter O'Tools,
and the da da da da, da da da, you know,
they get drunk, they get
high, they do what they do,
but they show up and they do their jobs.
So we were like, okay.
And that's what we did, you
know, we drank with him,
and we went to Styles Acting class.
We'd go smoke a joint and come in
and do our other acting classes,
or go build a set, or build some costumes,
or hang some lights and do all the things
that we had to do.
So I kept learning my
lessons and doing them.
- In different places
in life, I promise you,
you're going to find you
don't know where to go.
Everybody goes through this.
The most successful people
in the world wake up
some mornings with no
clue what to do today.
Okay, so first thing I want you to know
is that it's normal, it
happens to everybody.
It's not like you're a bad person
or you're lost or you're depressed
or you got some problem you
need to take medication for.
Everybody, everybody regardless
of their stature in life,
where they are, regardless of their money,
their relationship,
their job, they run the joint,
promise you, no matter
how much they present
like they look like got the
whole package put together,
everybody, everybody has those days,
and the sun is kicking today,
has those days where
they don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do, you know?
Uncertainty.
My friends Dale Christenson told me
when I was 25 years old.
I was experiencing depression every day,
he's like, no matter
what, man, no matter what,
no matter what, dude, show up.
Even if your eyes are bleeding, show up.
I've been doing that for 34 years now.
Show up, even when I don't want to, okay.
And then what I try to do is
I try to help one person, one person.
And what happened over
the period of 34 years,
I did that every day.
I'm not depressed anymore,
at least not for long periods of time.
I don't use any kind of medication,
don't use any kind of drugs.
Don't smoke weed, don't
drink over excessively drink,
I might have drink once in a while.
And got a beautiful
wife, two beautiful kids,
and for the most part my
life is freaking wonderful.
All I did was this.
I don't over analyze,
never do I label myself
a loser, a quitter.
I'm hard on myself.
I never label myself OCD, ACD, ADD, OCDD,
whatever a depressant, alcohol,
like a drug addict, no, no, I don't.
This is what I do, I do things, okay.
I show up, move in the direction,
I don't overanalyze, move in the direction
that I think could be more pro survival
than staying in one place.
And number three, help somebody.